what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
have been racking my brains for the last
like two days really two or three days
because I saw Avengers infinity war on
Friday so I'm racking my brains for the
last couple days I'm trying to figure
out how the movies gonna end how
Avengers 4 is gonna end and like what
role Carol Danvers is gonna play so so
here's the deal here's here's here's how
this whole thing goes so so carol
danvers real quick real quick
explanation on carol damage i've got two
great big huge videos that explain her
character so you're welcome to check
them out the Carol Danvers comes from a
series called Marvel superheroes and I
want to say it was like issue number 13
and she first made her appearance it so
back in like the the late 1960s in the
early 1970s for the most part in the
early 1960s superheroes were figured out
like Superman spider-man or not roasted
man a Spider Man Iron Man the return of
Captain America the Avengers Thor so on
and so forth Marvel wanted to introduce
new superheroes but the age of just
being able to print whatever they wanted
to in a solo series with people
guaranteed to buy it that had launched
it's gone and so the idea was well let's
just start making like anthology series
like DC used to do let's create series
where we just throw a whole bunch of
stories into a single comic so you get a
lot of bang for your buck and then we'll
just use letters pages and sales to
determine what it is a people liked the
most which is why you would see a
character like Marvel or Adam warlock
who would appear in like a whole bunch
of different you know anthology books
and then they would be out for one
because it would be a way to gauge
things it'd be way to look at that and
say okay did the sale slump when when
Adam warlock was out you know what
Marvel was out or did they continue to
rise because then people don't really
care about whether he's in it or not and
so it was it was kind of a cool idea but
the idea was this so you had a guy named
Marvel or the creep who was part of the
Kree race he was there was a story
called the kree-skrull war where he
basically ventured to earth join the
superheroes yadda yadda yadda and then
became a superhero on earth and Marvel
superheroes number 13 Carol Danvers I
think was introduced as like a Air Force
pilot working in like Cape Canaveral or
something like that I always get Cape
Canaveral and Cape Citadel mixed up one
of them was the place that magneto
attacked an event an x-men number four
or two whichever one it was that he
first appeared in and then the then the
other one is where Carol Danvers was but
regardless
Marvel shows up at whatever this
location is and he's in his human form
but he's being followed by this villain
called yon rock who's kind of like this
former military I guess he's really part
of like the military of the Kree Empire
who's been tasked with like
treating Marvel and bringing him back
and so the two of them get into a huge
fight Carol Danvers sees it and she's
like wow I'm really enamored by this guy
you know he has all kinds of powers and
stuff I wish I could be like him well
then it turns out that yan raw have
something called the psycho magnetron
and the psycho magnetron was basically a
plot device it was a wishing machine and
that if you were in the presence of it
or entrapped inside of it and then you
made a wish it would grant that wish and
so basically Carol Danvers had her genes
or had her
her DNA merged with that of Marvel
making her part Cree and then she went
for and went forward as Miss Marvel then
from like 1968 which i think is when her
first solo series started I don't know
brought on my head but from 1968 running
up until November the exact date that it
ended uh she was pretty popular like
she's like she was really really popular
initially and she was really popular
because she appealed to a lot of young
woman and she was really popular because
boys love the way she was drawn and so
because of that like she made a name for
herself and she was you know a pretty
cool superhero eventually your
popularity died out and Marvel was
trying to find a way to recreate her and
make her more interesting and so
eventually she was thrown on the x-men
team and I want to say that happened in
x-men annual and uncanny x-men annual
number 10 I could be wrong about that
but that was the first time that rogue
appeared in Marvel Comics now I'm sure
most people the question they're asking
is doesn't rogue have the same powers as
Captain Marvel as Carol Danvers yes and
here's the reason why so in this story
rogue is the daughter of mystique and
rogue basically is tasked by mistake
with invading Avengers mansion Kevin but
what the main purpose was but she
invades Avengers mansion and like
readily just like crushes everybody like
when I say rogue crushes everybody I
mean like she crushes everyone like she
grabs Thor and like absorbs his power
which gives her the ability to wield his
hammer and then like light just starts
readily just decimating people but in
this whole conflict because Carol
Danvers had kind of been rolled over
into the Avengers ended up happening is
rogues seize control of Carol Danvers
and held her long enough that she absorb
her powers her abilities and her
memories basically everything that made
that made Carol Danvers who she was
originally Carol Danvers is rolled over
into the x-men line of stories proper
and then she's let's see she stays as
Carol Danvers for a while and then like
in the actual spin in the other stories
you also have like the rogue Carol
Danvers persona fighting inside the mind
of
let's talk about that here in a second
but the Carol Danvers days part of the
x-men as Miss marvel for a while and
then I want to say it's like uncanny
x-men 161 through 166 there is this
story that Chris Claremont wrote about
the brute and I believe this story
coincides with the formation of the New
Mutants because Charles Xavier believe
that the x-men have been killed by the
brute so he forms a new mutants that
story that that whole line of comics
takes off but in this whole series of
events Carol Danvers is basically
alongside the x-men they're attacked by
the brood all kinds of things are
popping off and and what had happened
was the brooder basically experimented
on Carol Danvers they modified her genes
but they were curious about her because
she was a Kree human hybrid and so when
they modified her when they basically
messed with her jeans all that kind of
good stuff she essentially became binary
meaning she was able to like tap into a
white dwarf star it was a way for Chris
Claremont to basically say she can just
do things he hadn't done before it was
cool for a little while things actually
didn't really care for it too much and
the reason why was because their
philosophy was give us Carol Danvers as
Miss Marvel or don't give us anything at
all because with the whole rogues
situation the two of them word is kind
of going back and forth constantly now
that's that dead ends into like uncanny
x-men 247 I'm pretty sure and this is a
story that deals with something called
the siege perilous no those are guys who
don't know the siege perilous is
basically Chris Claremont version of
like a reboot device it's it's it was a
way for Chris Claremont to basically
have characters to like write characters
out have them pass through the siege
perilous and then their lives were able
to you know they could start their lives
over it was a way to like remove
characters for a temporary amount of
time to reboot characters in their
entirety or to just kind of like change
things up particularly when it came to
rope so because of the fact that rogue
and Carol Danvers personalities were
fighting amongst each other for quite
some time
fans were kind of growing it was kind of
going thin right it was like okay we
can't have these two fighting forever
you know dominance over the body and so
on and so forth and so in this story
what you had is you had master mole who
was the signal that made sentinels and
then you had a Nimrod who was the
Sentinel from the Days of Future Passed
universe who had crossed over from that
reality and enter the main Marvel
Universe in the present day and so their
storylines kind of coalesced came
together the x-men were fighting you
know mr. Sennett are fighting a master
mole they were fighting Nimrod and they
were gonna push them through the siege
perilous under the belief that they
would just be kind of wiped away in
their entire
the result is that rogue is ensnared
she's yanked at the siege perilous as
well master mold and Nimrod merged they
turn into a guy named Bastion which I
think eventually goes on to kick off
operation zero tolerance and then rogue
is just like she it like basically when
she passes through the Carol Danvers
persona slits off and the magneto kills
it so that's how the end of the whole
rogue Carol Danvers think for Carol
herself because of the fact that that it
was like okay we're tired of this whole
like I mean we like the idea of binary
but it didn't really like change her as
a character in terms of like making her
more interesting or more intriguing what
Marvel did is they had a story called
operation galactic storm now this is one
of those stories at Marvel Rights where
it's like okay this is the story we were
gonna do but why not use it to fix
things that we want to fix so it was
kind of like Marvel's version of like
Infinite Crisis from DC or like Final
Crisis from DC or even zero our crisis
sometime from DC Comics and so an
operation galactic storm what we ended
up finding out is that sometime in their
early history the Kree race had
encountered something called a crystal
of ultimate vision and the idea was that
if you harnessed it it would give you
ultimate vision in ultimate power um
what is it happening is that for those
who aren't ready to wield it who aren't
capable they're entirely the entire
evolution of their race will stagnate
it'll stop dead in its tracks and
they'll never evolve and so when you
were the Kree and you were facing off
against the scrolls in the crease for
war which had been going on for millions
of years and the scrolls were evolving
and the Kree weren't what it meant is
that them losing the war was inevitable
they would ultimately die off and so the
leader of the Kree the supreme
intelligence have this genius idea of
saying okay like we're gonna pick a
fight with the Shiar Empire because
they're like the super advanced race of
a race of aliens who all swear
allegiance to the Magister and
magistrates
they picked this baby huge fight the
stories nineteen parts it crosses over
with like Thor and Captain America and
like quasar and I think
Wonder Man and like the The Avengers and
a camera preface Avengers west coast or
west coast avengers because they renamed
him after a while um but in the event
like it's this huge great big huge story
ultimately the Shiar detonate like this
massive bomb in space it wipes out 90%
of the Kree race and then we find out
that was the whole plan that was a plan
all along was to push the Kree race to
the brink of extinction so that they
would have to evolve that evolution
would override the power of the crystal
of ultimate vision which I guess it
wasn't that powerful to
and then the Cree would basically evolve
and they could essentially have a chance
at winning the war against the scrolls
um in that whole story Carol Danvers
lost the binary component to her body
and what that meant was that she was no
longer able to harbor the power of like
a white dwarf star instead she kind of
reverted back to her normal self all
being able to tap into those powers a
little bit so she was she was changed
just slightly to where she was a little
bit different than she was before
but by and large she was still the same
that runs all the way up to the modern
day like there's really been no change
in her character since then you very
rarely ever see her use binary powers
but she can and sometimes she does
depending on who's writing the story in
terms of Carol Danvers becoming Captain
Marvel that went on like she was Miss
Marvel for years like she was Miss
Marvel she was binary she was like
warbird in the late late nineteen
nineteen nineties I think or something
like that um she's had different names
over the years unless she's largely been
called Miss Marvel she adopted the
Captain Marvel name as part of Marvel
now I think it I think it was Kelly sue
Taconic who was right in the story um
and she essentially took up the mantle
of the hero she idolized so long because
Marvel had been dead since 1919 for 1984
no one had ever picked up the mantilla
Captain America was like man take it
nobody cares so like you know she ended
up taking it and she became you know and
became Captain Marvel but nonetheless
that's that's kind of the gist of her
character the question people want to
know is Captain Marvel and the MCU how
will she compare well one brie Larson
looks up marries and it's Captain Marvel
which I'm really excited about she's a
beautiful woman and two um no way
Captain Marvel stands a chance against
Thanos but the sea like here's the funny
thing though here's here's a crazy thing
Thanos was nerfed pretty severely an
infinity war like his power was reduced
pretty like it by a pretty huge margin
my pre huge clip half those fights that
went on and infinity war Thanos could
have won without the cut without the
Infinity Gauntlet like he could have won
those fights without using that thing
with the Infinity Gauntlet each one of
those flights should've been five
seconds long like I mean it like they
never should have been that drawn-out
but it wouldn't have made for a very
interesting movie like it would have
just been Thanos quest and you would
have had any real conflict or any real
battle and most people are aware of that
like most people are aware looking at
like the Infinity Gauntlet what it can
do if it's powerful enough to bleak out
half a life in the universe to just make
hath life the universe cease to exist
then why did any of those fights stretch
on for as long as they did its to make
an interesting movie you know so you all
sit there and watch it
Wow you know something that that kind of
thing makes sense but I mean even if
Thanos in its base form has even a
modicum of power in in you know relation
to the kind of book form then there's no
way Carol Danvers stands a chance but
that's kind of the funny thing that's a
question you have to ask did fan OHS use
the power stone when he fought Hulk like
I mean that did that that happened I
guess kind of a spoiler but if you went
into this video not knowing there'll be
spoilers I don't know what to tell you
so um with like like did he use the
power stone when he fought hawk if he
did well then you'll probably use it
when he fights Carol Danvers if not then
dance was just that damn strong so I
don't know it kind of depends um having
said that of course we know Carol
Danvers will be in there I think she'll
just be another one of the superheroes
who's there I think she'll have like her
like a couple bright moments here in
there because like she's basically the
new kid on the block
she's like the hero that we haven't
really seen yet I mean her solo movie
will come out before infinity war by
like two months I'm sorry before
Avengers four by two months but people
are gonna want to see like how she faces
off against Thanos that's what people
want to see because her movies gonna
take place in the 90s so it's not like
you know it takes place as a tie-in to
infinity war like it takes place in the
90s so people are gonna want to see how
she manages to hold her own against
Thanos
um I think she'll be able to do it
temporarily but I don't think she'd be
able to do it for any real measure of
time because she's just not strong
enough Carol Danvers never was her Oh
Danvers was never strong enough to be
able to hold her own against Thanos for
any real measure of time like I mean
she's just not on that level but well I
guess classic Thanos newer Thanos
probably classic Thanos no no way uh
having said that the big question in
that then I think a lot of people are
kind of kind of asking here is how will
this whole thing end like like how will
Avengers 4 end like like what's the
conclusion of all this okay so here's
the deal so a Marvel Comics you have a
character called Adam warlock most
everybody knows about Adam warlock by
now because he's essentially like space
Jesus you know it's really his whole
thing though you know so I don't more
like being space Jesus a lot of people
are like okay if Adam warlock is not
going to be in Avengers 4 and he's not
going to show up until guardians of the
galaxy 3 then who's going to play his
role because in Infinity Gauntlet which
is basically what both of infinity war
and Avengers 4 based on and the Infinity
Gauntlet story it's Adam warlock who
marshals all the the heroes together
it's Adam warlock who grabs what's left
of the earth superheroes and brings them
together
it's Adam warlock who brings in like the
cosmic entities is Adam warlock who does
all that stuff
who engineers the entire downfall of
Thanos up to and including nebula
snatching they got one off his hands
which is how I think that Avengers four
will end in terms of like Adam or like
not being there I think Captain
America's gonna take its place I think
Steve Rogers and iron man are gonna go
like fix the rift or it's gonna be like
a temporary truce they might still be
kind of crumbling in each other although
when half the life in the universe gets
destroyed by a by a demigod
who's virtually unstoppable I think it's
time to put your problems aside because
at the end of the day civil war doesn't
really matter in comparison to like a
universal level threat and so because of
that like I think they're gonna put
their problems aside they're gonna
become four come besties again and I
think they're gonna take a page out of
the Jonathan Hickman's infinity and I
think they're gonna say Captain America
is gonna be the one who's gonna marshal
all the forces together and Captain
America is gonna be the one who's
basically going to like lead the charge
against Stannis but again like the earth
superheroes won't succeed there's no way
they could unless the Infinity Gauntlet
is somehow reduced in power from what it
was an infinity war which wouldn't make
any sense to me because you know they're
they're in there Infinity stones they're
not finite stones they're not like you
know they're not Infinity stones up to a
point like I mean it doesn't work that
way there are a source of infinite power
so that you can't really decrease their
abilities I mean it's infinite infinite
energy so because of the fact of the
Infinity Gottman's probably just as
powerful and Avengers for as it is an
infinity war none of the heroes are
gonna stand a chance we've seen that
play out what I think is gonna happen I
think we're gonna see the return of the
Celestials we know that like the deal
between Fox and and Disney hasn't really
gone through yet so like we probably
won't see like a lot kiss or any of that
stuff but we know the Celestials exist
and we could see the Celestials come
back now the question people have is how
in the world are they gonna fit the
Celestials in okay in Marvel Comics
there was a story that was written about
a villain called apocalypse and it took
place in x-men vol 2 184 through 187
anyway the story called the blood of
apocalypse which we covered the idea was
that apocalypse was just an earth-based
villain who was immortal somewhere along
the line but then he just like develop
this ability to tap into like super
advanced technology because cable made
that happened by screwing up and then he
was able to like harness that type know
that technology which the Celestials
allowed him to do and the celestial said
like we will return for a future
which is the blood of apocalypse story
how all that stuff comes together and
fits in now what I imagine them doing is
saying like like this one we don't know
how Thanos learned about the Infinity
stones
we just know he has them like we know
he's aware of them
like the post quite a scene in Avengers
you know like the Infinity stones given
to Loki throughout the whole movie
Loki uses it he's ultimately defeated
like that's the end of that the space
stone is you know held by shield I can
who was it took it after that but any of
that like you know Dallas is aware of
the Infinity stones we never find out
how he became aware of the Infinity
stones we just know he is now what we
could argue here what we could say is
that Fano somewhere along the line after
you know whatever it was that he did on
his homeworld destroying you know what
have you somewhere along the line Thanos
learned about the Infinity stones and he
learned about the Infinity stones from
the Celestials and the Celestials like
he basically took them a celestial set
were you gonna use these for and it's
like well I'm gonna use it to destroy
half life in the universe probably lied
and the celestial said fine you can use
them but we'll take them back for a
future payments later or something along
those lines or he stole them and or Sol
you know the the you know I guess learn
whatever it is he learned about them
from the Celestials and the Celestials
themselves you know will eventually be
involved in in Avengers 4 to me that
makes sense using that as a means to
bring the Celestials in because we know
the Infinity stones goes all the way
back to the Celestials the Infinity
stones are part and parcel to the
universe itself when the universe was
made the Infinity stones came into
existence but we also know the
Celestials use them and so we can
basically say like the Celestials are
still around they're still free-floating
out there who knows what they've been
doing you know playing Texas Hold'em all
this time who knows what the Celestials
am into it just kind of been hanging out
you know and watching TV like they've
been when they've been binge watching
like different binge watching black New
York is what they've been doing that's
all they've been doing like binge
watching The Office but like they're
they're hanging out they show up and
they they get involved but here's the
sees this is a funny thing
if the Infinity Gauntlet is used at its
full power lettuces say Thanos basically
like engages in this massive battle and
each one of the stones are used to their
benefits meaning he uses the space stone
to open up a portal and then enhances it
with a time stone which means he opens
up a portal to the Past then like he
just starts throwing people into the
past like if he uses the space stone and
the reality stone throws people into
other dimensions like I mean there's
there's different things that you can do
with those because you can you can use
the Infinity Gauntlet in other
dimensions you can't use the Infinity
Gauntlet another you know
philsie guys who don't know what that
means each universe has its own set of
dimensions each universe has its own
Asgard each universe has its own version
of Hell each universe has its own door
monitor so you know each universe has
its own different dimension that exists
in their various dimensions so you can
do that with the Infinity Gauntlet the
Celestials even then wouldn't stand a
chance because the stones are so
powerful and Thanos is so smart but
again it depends on how they do it
because there's been big changes in
infinity war the affinity stones don't
seem to be as powerful as they were like
in the comics we're just fine you know I
mean it makes for a movie that's
reasonable because like I said if they
have taken the Infinity stones and
feyo's exactly as they existed in the
comics and rolled him over to the movies
and gave us that movie that movie would
be half an hour long it would just be
like it would it would not be any it
wouldn't be interesting it'd be like hey
it'd be like 10 minutes of fighting not
even that it'd be like a minute and a
half of fighting overall and then it
would be like 91 minutes of talking like
it would not be anything it wouldn't be
interesting at all people would feel
like this movie sucks and like they
would leave they would walk out because
it'd be so much dialogue so I don't know
I mean it'll go different like who knows
what direction it'll go in but either
way like I'm excited regardless of how
this plays out I'm super hyped because I
think that this movie is gonna turn out
to be something absolutely bonkers I
think Carol Danvers will be just another
superhero who's there my money is that
they're gonna roll the Eternals over
into the MCU like they're gonna bring
them in because they're already touring
with a movie what better way to like
bolster the chances of success than
using the Eternals cuz like they're
wildly powerful they're not Celestials
powerful but they're wildly powerful but
but again I mean you know I have no clue
we know let me tribunal exist we don't
know if a living tribunal will intervene
we have no clue because at this point
it's a crapshoot like I mean like like
there's what we expected and then
there's what they gave us and they
basically took dynamite and they tied it
around all of our expectations and blew
it to pieces so now it's a crapshoot
like there's no there's no knowing
what's gonna happen in Avengers 4 which
actually makes the movie even more
exciting if I'd seen exactly what I saw
in the comics it wouldn't be nearly as
interesting because I could predict the
ending I said the ending will be nebula
taking the gauntlet off Thanos I think
that'll be how it ends I think you'll
get cocky he'll get arrogant in the
midst of battle he'll make himself part
of the universe or whatever and she'll
snaps they call it away from them I
don't know maybe Hawkeye will do
something and get the gauntlet who knows
but either way like I'm super hyped I'm
super excited I think it'll be one heck
of a movie like it's gonna be pretty
amazing I don't know I need to think
about this kind of stuff I didn't think
about this more then actually see if I
can't develop a plan on how I think the
universe will end cuz right now this is
just off the top of my head or at least
how Avengers for will him this is just
kind of off top my head but anyway guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here - comments explain
it make sure you guys have the sub
button when you come part of the Robin
Corps if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]